[Música]
en este programa especial sobre las
elecciones en francia les contaremos
cómo funcionan estos comicios y quiénes
son los candidatos más opcionados para
llegar al palacio del elíseo y liderar
durante el próximo periodo de cinco años
el presidente de manuel ma hope confirmó
en última instancia su intención de
buscar la reelección lo hizo por medio
de una carta a los franceses la fecha
límite era el 4 de marzo y el consejo
constitucional
oficializará a la lista de los
candidatos el día 7 tenemos las
reacciones
la inmigración polariza los comicios en
francia mientras la derecha ha llegado a
caer en teorías conspirativas sobre como
los mil grandes reemplazarán a la raza
blanca el centro y la izquierda proponen
medidas para beneficiarlos les
explicamos por qué
bienvenidos a este nuevo programa cada
sábado en france 24 sobre las elecciones
en francia y es que nuestro canal les
contará qué está pasando en la campaña
electoral gala comencemos entonces por
entender cómo funcionan las
presidenciales en francia la primera
vuelta está programada para el 10 de
abril pero la segunda pero según la
intención de voto de las encuestas
ninguno de los más de 40 posibles
candidatos tendría más del 50 por ciento
que se necesita para ganar directamente
lo que podría llevar a una segunda
vuelta en el siguiente informe hacemos
un panorama de lo más relevante de los
comicios y quiénes son los aspirantes
principales
francia se alista para elegir a quien
será su presidente por los próximos
cinco años las fechas están definidas
para ganar en la primera vuelta del 10
de abril alguien tendría que obtener más
de 50% de los votos algo poco probable
por lo que una segunda ronda electoral
está prevista para el 24 de abril
para poder presentarse un candidato
debía obtener 500 avales de cargos
públicos electos el consejo
constitucional recibió las
documentaciones hasta el 4 de marzo y la
lista oficial de los candidatos se
conocerá el 7 del mismo mes el actual
presidente de manuel marco confirmó su
candidatura el jueves y aspirará a un
segundo mandato actualmente es el
favorito de los sondeos de tus encuestas
que le auguran posibles enfrentamientos
en una hipotética segunda vuelta
por un lado valérie pécresse es la
candidata de los republicanos
una mujer de derecha que se define como
dos tercios angela merkel y un tercio
marca de thatcher y por otro una posible
opción ada es una vieja rival martine
depende del partido agrupación nacional
a quien marco derrotó en 2017 representa
a la extrema derecha sin embargo en esta
ocasión sus opciones se ven amenazadas
por la posible candidatura de herri que
se move un polemista que fue condenado
dos veces por incitación al odio racial
y que tiene posiciones radicales sobre
la inmigración y la defensa de la
identidad francesa la izquierda llega
debilitada y dividida los sondeos dan
pocas esperanzas para que un candidato
logre alcanzar el escrutinio del 24 de
abril
cristian toga antigua ministra de
justicia de françois hollande ganó
ampliamente la primaria popular pero
retiró su candidatura esta semana y
sigue en carrera han hidalgo la
alcaldesa de parís la candidata del
partido socialista que no había
desconocido dichos resultados al igual
que es un look meloso quien se lanza por
tercera vez por francia y sumisa y que
se presenta como el candidato que busca
romper con el neoliberalismo la
candidatura verde que han manos de
yannick jadot y la comunista en la de
fabián hoss él
cuando faltaban menos de 24 horas para
el cierre de las candidaturas a las
elecciones presidenciales en francia el
actual mandatario manuel marco
finalmente anunció su intención de
buscar la reelección los días previos al
anuncio estuvieron marcados por el
inicio de la invasión rusa en ucrania en
la que más ha intentado tener un rol
mediador a través de una carta dirigida
al pueblo francés defendió lo que puede
hacer de estos tiempos de crisis en la
historia tanto francesa como europea
o no
a las elecciones presidenciales de
francia aunque ya había expresado su
intención de presentarse los franceses
esperaban su declaración oficial desde
semanas y en plena de la guerra en
ucrania fue un anuncio discreto con una
carta publicada en internet que podría
ser al igual que su campaña electoral
por supuesto no podré hacer campaña como
me hubiera gustado debido al contexto
pero con claridad y compromiso explicaré
nuestro proyecto nuestra voluntad de
seguir sacando adelante nuestro país con
cada uno de ustedes
el presidente francés defiende su
gestión que estuvo marcada por la crisis
de los chalecos amarillos del cobi 19 y
más recientemente de la crisis con malí
y de la guerra en ucrania mcqueen existe
también sobre el desafío económico y en
materia del medio ambiente para el país
no hay independencia sin fuerza
económica por lo tanto tendremos que
trabajar más y seguir bajando los
impuestos al trabajo y a la producción
también debemos seguir invirtiendo en
nuestra innovación e investigación para
situar a francia en la vanguardia de
sectores como las energías renovables la
energía nuclear las baterías la
la tecnología digital y el espacio según
los sondeos makoun tiene todas las
posibilidades de llegar a la segunda
vuelta de la elección en la cual se
enfrentaría probablemente a la candidata
de derecha
valérie pécresse oa un candidato de
extrema derecha el ix de move o su
antigua rival marín lópez
las reacciones al tardío anuncio de
manuel ma com llegaron desde todo el
espectro político los candidatos de
extrema derecha se opusieron al proyecto
del presidente de cara a un eventual
segundo mandato la derecha considera que
majo ha debilitado a francia y la
izquierda llama a romper con el status
quo un anuncio de candidatura que generó
múltiples reacciones desde el mundo
político después de la carta de los
franceses difundida por emanuel mack con
los otros aspirantes a la presidencia no
tardaron en pronunciarse los mensajes de
los candidatos de ultraderecha marine
lepén de agrupación nacional y eriksen
de reconquista buscaron ser contundentes
qué es lo que tengo para responder a
esta carta que leí rápidamente que estoy
en desacuerdo con él con cada una de las
líneas y que voy a hacer todo para que
los próximos años no sean con él sino
conmigo
por fin la oposición de las dos francias
de los dos proyectos podrá desarrollarse
ante los franceses otros candidatos se
manifestaron satisfechos de poder por
fin debatir con el actual presidente y
aprovecharon para lanzar críticas a sus
cinco años de mandato los hechos son
innegables
la política hecha durante los últimos
cinco años debilitó a francia
y el 10 y 24 de abril los franceses y
las francesas deben poder elegir entre
diferentes modelos de sociedad y si
continuamos como antes en el statu quo
con emanuel macro
la tardanza en su postulación también
fue juzgada por sus contrincantes
inscritos en su patio y yo creo que los
franceses no se dejan engañar por todo
esto todo está hecho para que no haya
campaña en manuel macrón está en campaña
desde hace un mes con su dinero o
decenas de miles de millones fueron
votados con las ventanas con con falsas
promesas como la vez pasada tipales net
de sus meses con mañana fue la lista
definitiva de los candidatos
presidenciales será oficializada el
próximo lunes 7 de marzo por el consejo
constitucional y después de este repaso
por los candidatos ahora veamos cómo van
las encuestas según el estudio de ipsos
declarado la primera vuelta del actual
presidente de manuel bajo lidera la
intención de voto con un 24% seguido por
la candidata de derecha del partido de
los republicanos
valérie pécresse quien tiene un 15 5 %
la ultraderechista marine le pen tiene
un 15 por ciento y también el
ultraderechista el ex en la sigue de
cerca con un 14,5 por ciento
la encuesta señala además que en caso
tal de pasar a segunda vuelta más cumple
ganaría a todos los candidatos
y le pen obtendría un
57% si se enfrenta a eric se obtendría
un 62 por ciento de los votos y en un
eventual desempate contra la valeria y
pgr también le daría la victoria con un
54 por ciento de la intención de voto a
pesar de que según las estimaciones de
ihs o los principales temas de
preocupación de los franceses son la
economía y la salud la inmigración es
una vez más uno de los grandes temas de
discusión en esta campaña los candidatos
de ultraderecha son quienes más se han
referido al tema con una teoría de la
conspiración llamada el gran reemplazo
pero ésta ha sido incluso acuñada por
candidatos de la derecha tradicional
hablamos con leslie carretero periodista
del portal informe gantz quien nos
explicó que significa la teoría del gran
reemplazo
[Música]
el gran reemplazo es una expresión que
apareció a finales del siglo 19 es decir
hace ya mucho tiempo fue democratizado a
finales de 2010 2011 por un autor
francés nacionalista que se llama gen o
para muse y hoy es una teoría
ampliamente retomada por los candidatos
de extrema derecha y también por valérie
pécresse candidata del partido los
republicanos un partido de derecha ha
generado polémica en francia porque es
la primera vez que un o una candidata de
la derecha republicana utiliza esta
expresión que es una expresión xenófoba
y conspirativa esto porque estima que la
población europea será reemplazada por
poblaciones no blancas y no cristianas o
sea negras y musulmanas para decir las
cosas como son y es entonces la
desaparición de la cultura europea para
los adeptos de esta teoría se trata de
un declive demográfico
y así llegamos al final de nuestro
programa dedicado a las elecciones en
francia los invitamos a que sigan con
nosotros aquí en france 24
[Música]